since its announcement hulu's biopic pam
and tommy has been wrapped up in
controversy the series depicts a more
idealistic time in the mid 90s when
celebrity sex tapes were not as frequent
as they have come to be this caused a
perfect storm for pamela anderson played
by lily james and tommy lee played by
sebastian stan when their private
honeymoon video was stolen from the poem
many have come out against even the idea
of such a series portraying the story
the notorious singer for the grunge band
hole courtney love defended anderson's
right to privacy she said in a statement
my heart goes out to pamy further
causing her complex trauma love's
statement refers to how anderson was
treated by the press at the time she was
publicly shamed by many outlets and
according to entertainment weekly she
refuses to ever watch the show the new
hulu series is from i tonya director
craig gillespie who was also criticized
for a sympathetic portrayal of tonya
harding in his previous film in addition
to these factors there is one former
band member that has some strong
opinions about lee's portrayal and pam
and tommy formed in 1981 motley crue was
a hair metal band that quickly became
known for their antics one of the most
famous anecdotes is the time ozzy
osbourne snorted a line of ants which is
detailed in the band's memoir and film
of the same name dirt what may be lesser
known is the brief period of time when
man vince neil left the band which is
not portrayed in pam and tommy in 1992
neil was replaced by john karabi who
performed with the band for five years
karabe sang on the band's self-titled
album in 1994 and did not continue when
neal returned for the comeback album in
1997. for sebastian stan's
transformation into tommy lee the actor
reached out and lee officially gave his
blessing to pam and tommy despite this
korrabi does not agree with how lee is
portrayed in the limited series in a
powerful statement on his social media
korabi defended many players who this
real life story touched on his twitter
account koorabi published a lengthy
statement in defense of the real-life
people who were involved in the story
behind pam and tommy the singer was
adamant that the character of lee in the
show is a work of fiction and not
relevant to reality karabe wrote in his
statement i shared five years of my life
with tommy and although at times it was
insanity it's so overblown the singer
went on to explain that these events
were sensationalized for what they call
tv entertainment in the show lee is
often demonstrated as being outrageous
and often times cruel the main catalyst
for the aforementioned break-in and
subsequent theft of anderson and lee's
sex tape was because of lee's treatment
of his former carpenter rant gottier
gotea expected to be paid for materials
and to retrieve his tools from lee's
property instead lee met him with a
shotgun and refused to pay him later in
the series anderson is shocked to hear
that lee refused to pay for services
rendered kharavi's defense isn't just
extended to lee there's another
significant person who he goes to the
map for pamela anderson was a sad
footnote at the time of the scandal as
portrayed in pam and tommy anderson had
to face the brunt of abuse from
comedians like jay leno while he was
often let off easily from the limelight
karabe has come to her defense and lied
to this trauma too he wrote on twitter
apparently hulu and all involved in this
croc don't care about how pam may feel
to have to relive this his concern also
extended to anderson and lee's two sons
who they continue to co-parent despite
the end of their marriage there are
elements of anderson's life that are not
in kohlrabi's statement and are entirely
glossed over in pam and tommy as well
ashoba's cheat sheet states the couple
briefly reconciled after lee spent time
in prison due to spousal abuse the hulu
series mentions the domestic violence in
anderson and lee's relationship briefly
in the end credits but did not make that
a priority in the series nor did karabe
mention it in his twitter post anderson
has been through many trials because of
his time in her life and continues to
stick by her decision not to be involved
with the show
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]